hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the house expected to vote on whether to
begin a second impeachment of president
trump
with democrats accusing the
commander-in-chief of inciting an
insurrection at the u.s capitol last
week
former deputy independent council on the
whitewater investigation
solomon weisenberg breaks down what the
process will look like
and the timing of it all just seven days
before president-elect joe biden's
inauguration
in the trump administration revamping
its covet 19 vaccine distribution
strategy in an effort
to speed up the process dr marty mccary
a professor of surgery and health policy
at the johns hopkins university school
of medicine
and a fox news medical contributor
weighs in on the rollout
and shares his take on the government's
latest vaccine guidelines
plus commentary from syndicated
columnist cal thomas
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm red bear i'm maria bartromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday january 13th 2021
i'm lisa brady president trump is
condemning
the violent attack on the u.s capitol
but he might get impeached again
anyway we're talking about an attack on
congress performing a solemn function
after a speech by the president of the
united states we have never seen that
in our history and hopefully we will
never see it again
i'm dave anthony there's a new push to
pick up the pace of coronavirus
vaccinations
especially for older americans we've
lost 10 percent of our nursing home
population in the united states from
covid
the case fatality rate is as high as 20
last week was the deadliest week in
nursing homes in america
let's put our vulnerable people ahead of
ourselves and i'm kel thomas i've got
the final word on the fox news rundown
it would be unprecedented for the same
us president to be impeached
twice but it might happen to president
donald trump
a year ago he was impeached by the house
then acquitted in the senate
after a phone call pressing ukraine's
leader to investigate the bidens
now he's facing an article of
impeachment over last week's deadly
assault on the capital
accused of inciting insurrection
millions of our citizens watched
on wednesday as a mob stormed the
capitol and trashed the halls of
government
during a visit to the southern border
wall in texas on tuesday
president trump condemned the violence
but also the impeachment effort
the impeachment hoax is a continuation
of the greatest and most vicious witch
hunt
in the history of our country and is
causing tremendous anger and division
and pain
the president also dismissing the house
resolution calling on vice president
mike pence to invoke the 25th amendment
to remove him from office
pence dismissing that too in a letter to
house speaker nancy pelosi writing
that he doesn't think it's in the best
interest of the country or
consistent with the constitution
president trump also said tuesday that
free speech is under assault and he
defends his remarks at a rally before
rioters stormed the capitol
as totally appropriate senate democratic
leader chuck schumer
calls that despicable blaming others for
what he caused
is a pathological technique used by the
worst of dictators
some republican lawmakers are now
breaking ranks and do plan to vote for
impeachment including the number three
republican in the house
wyoming congresswoman liz chaney who
says the president
assembled the mob and lit the flame of
the attack
then failed to forcefully intervene to
stop it the push to punish the president
moving full steam ahead regardless of
whether he accepts any blame well he's
almost certainly correct as a matter of
federal criminal law and first amendment
law that he did not
commit the crime of incitement saul
weisenberg was a deputy independent
counsel during the investigation of
president bill clinton and is a fox news
contributor
he did not advocate overthrow of the
government for example
uh he is certainly wrong that his call
was
that his speech was appropriate and
i'm sure um nobody responsible would
have told him that
since it's congress we're talking about
though
um moving forward with impeachment
possibly a second time
or and or you know urging the vice
president to invoke the 25th amendment
but even in the context of an
impeachment trial in congress let's say
do are they held to the same legal
standards
as an incitement charge would carry in
court so i mean how much evidence does
congress need
to try to prove that well first of all
you do not have to have a crime
to to be found
to be impeached the overwhelming
majority of constitutional scholars
are in agreement that high crimes and
misdemeanors
which is the impeachment standard was it
was a term of art and
was not confined to the criminal law so
uh i think that pretty much answers the
question
uh they don't have to prove a crime to
impeach him uh you have a situation here
looking at it from the house majority's
point of view
where the president of the united states
exhorted a crowd to interfere with a
solemn constitutional function
of the house and the senate and i think
that's how they're viewing it and they
don't want to let this stand
now you also ask the question about the
25th amendment
that's completely different and i think
it's wrong
for speaker pelosi to
demand the vice president pence invoke
the 25th amendment that's extortion and
the 25th amendment doesn't apply here it
applies to a president who's
incapacitated
and i don't believe you can make a case
that president trump
is in capacity so
a resolution passed by the house
certainly doesn't compel
the vice president to take any action
but that's a pretty strong word you're
using talking about pelosi extortion
well i mean it's not crim
it's not criminal extortion but it is
you know she's basically extorting him
uh
to do something that i don't believe
he is allowed to do under the
constitution and if you're really
offended by what the president did and
if you really believe it's an
impeachable offense
and that it's so important that he has
to be impeached before he leaves office
why he waited this long i mean the the
assault on the capitol happened last
wednesday
i can see waiting a day to draw up the
article of impeachment but
why have we waited this long if you're
that outraged fight
go ahead and do it take the vote it's
been a year
since the house impeached president
trump the first time
are the parameters the same in terms of
needing a simple majority vote in the
house but then a two-thirds
vote in the senate to convict does that
all stay the same
right the constitution does not change
now there is some authority for the
proposition
that if he is convicted which requires a
two-thirds vote in the senate
that the senate could then vote by
majority
to prevent him from ever holding office
again
really that question is not is not is
not settled for all time
but that's the general consensus but you
absolutely
have to have a majority to impeach and a
two-thirds majority to convict
we also really don't have a lot of
authority for the proposition that
you can remove somebody from office
after they're impeached
once they've left office so he will be
out of office on january the 20th the
senate is not going to be able to vote
on
an impeachment article until after he
has left office
it's not at all clear that
they can do that once he has left office
they've done it
before with the secretary of war under
u.s
grant but this is the president and
there is language in the constitution
implying that he would still have to be
in office for that to work so nobody
knows for sure
what punishment could he face then as a
former president
other than the move to try to make sure
that he couldn't run again
well in terms of of the impeachment
process
it does not go beyond removal from
office
or prevention of running again or having
any office or
title congress does not have the power
to criminalize what he what he did that
would be the result
of a federal criminal investigation and
based on what we know now obviously that
investigation is going to be ongoing
based on what we know now
it's highly unlikely that the president
would be
guilty of any crime you know there's a
statute that not enough people have been
focusing on though i noticed that
uh the acting u.s attorney for dc
focused on it in this press conference
that's michael sherwood
which is a sedition or seditious
conspiracy
that's really a more appropriate statute
for what the people did
who led the assault on the capitol
building
last week that talks about two or more
people
conspiring to
[Music]
destroy property of the government to
hinder or delay
execution of the law or to
obstruct the authority of the government
so i think that's what
the prosecutors are going to be looking
at for the ringleaders of this and the
people who participated in
but it sounds like you don't think
that there's really the possibility of a
criminal charge against donald trump
private citizen
over this attack once he's out of office
certainly not for incitement
because we we've seen the video and that
just
simply does not constitute criminal
conduct
so unless something comes out uh
where he conspired or aided and embedded
in the
in in the actual destruction that
happened
which strikes me as highly unlikely
to have evidence developed in that
direction then
he would not be subject to prosecution
for that for the people who breached the
capital
federal prosecutors say the dozens of
charges and arrests so far
are just the beginning we're looking at
everything from simple trespass
to theft of mail to theft of digital
devices with inside the capital
assaulting officers felony murder and
theft of potential national security
information
also not being ruled out and u.s
attorney michael sherwin says
there's a new strike force to focus on
possible sedition counts
their only marching orders from me are
to build
seditious and conspiracy charges related
to the most heinous
acts that occurred in the capital but
democrats and some republicans want to
hold
president trump accountable in some way
for what they see as his role
in encouraging the violence would
something other than a second
impeachment
be an appropriate tool well people have
talked about a censure
of the president but it's obvious
that at least the majority in the house
believe that that's not enough and that
the members of congress need to be
on record as condemning in the strongest
possible terms
what happened what happened last
wednesday the president crossed the
rubicon there's no
there's no question of that what
happened was absolutely inexcusable
you can't look at his speech in
isolation you have to look
at the campaign over the last
month month and a half since the
election uh
the statements about vice president
pence the pressure on vice president
pence the book the build-up on social
media you have to look at all of that
when you judge the president's behavior
not again again not as a criminal law
matter
but as members of the national
legislature deciding how they're going
to deal with this this is not
this is not just like any other thing
that the president has done
to them this is something that is
unlike anything he's ever done and that
is very serious
we're talking about an attack on
congress performing a solemn function
after a speech by the president of the
united states we have never seen that
in our history and hopefully we will
never see it again
if you were part of trump's
legal team what advice would you be
giving to the president
and what kind of behavior would you be
discouraging at this point
well i would discourage a statement
that i have been told that my speech was
appropriate or entirely appropriate
i would i would not encourage
behavior such as that because it's
likely to increase the chances
of not only impeachment but of
the senate voting by two-thirds to go
further
or by like we talked about by majority
vote
uh to keep him from running again
sal weisenberg thank you very very much
for your time we appreciate it
no problem thank you
[Music]
this is cal thomas with your fox news
commentary coming up
it's been one month since the first
doses of the first approved coronavirus
vaccine from pfizer
were sent across the country now with
moderna's version also going out they
have shipped
nearly 38 million total doses of vaccine
to date
and health and human services secretary
alex azar says about 9 million
have been shot into people's arms
however the surgeon general dr jerome
adams tells fox
we're in a race against this virus and
quite frankly
we're behind and a big reason for that
we're seeing the
post holiday surge surge with records
set this month in daily new cases
and deaths cdc director dr robert
redfield
says most of transmission that is
occurring in our nation right now is not
occurring in the public square
it's occurring one household to one
household to one household and that is
driving calls to get more people
vaccinated
faster so secretary azar is urging
states
they should open vaccinations to all of
their most
vulnerable people now recommending
everyone 65 and over should get a covet
vaccine shot and those younger
who have an underlying medical condition
as well we are releasing the entire
supply we have
for order by states rather than holding
second doses
in physical reserve something
president-elect biden has already
suggested he would do when he takes over
the government decided to hold back
fifty percent of the vaccine supply plus
an additional five percent buffer
to reserve second doses dr marty mccary
is a professor of surgery and health
policy
at johns hopkins and a fox news medical
contributor
that came on the recommendation of dr
anthony fauci and a lot of the old guard
career staff right the
people the fda who have been there
forever who have said look this is the
only way
that we can give it because it's the
only way it's been studied well guess
what
when you look at the protective effect
after a single dose
there's decent protection after one dose
and
actually if you get the second dose a
little late
a week late a month late the amount of
vulnerability you have to
serious covet infection is negligible i
mean it's tiny
look the immunity level maybe as high as
80 to 90 percent after a month before
you get your second dose
okay so that tells you that there's a
lot of power
in that first dose and we're not just
worried about
people getting the infection we're also
worried about people dying from the
infection and no one who's received a
first dose has ever died of the
infection
okay so that means let's get as many
first doses out there as possible
all right in the new cdc recommendation
they want to have anyone over 65
now get the vaccine and those under that
age you have pre-existing medical
conditions so
that is going to be more people who are
eligible now to get this vaccine
yeah we've got about 50 million
americans over the age of 65 and they
should be
i think in my opinion they should be
right at the top of the list we've come
up with these convoluted structures of
giving out the vaccine by
job and your profession and what you do
and
you know as even as a health care worker
myself
i think just a simple age-based
allocation would have
streamlined the process because the
confusion that
this this complicated tiering structure
is creating especially when it's
sort of redone by the states right they
take the cdc guidance and then they
revise it so it's like every state has
this own its own tiering system
its own group 1b and 2a
if we would have just said immunize the
oldest americans first
on down we would have saved more lives
that's what the uk is doing
that's what a lot of europe is doing
that's what saves the most number of
lives and that's what increases the
speed
of getting the shots in people's arms
but the healthcare workers
who are in the emergency room or in icus
i mean they're on the front lines
they're dealing with people
who have covert right in front of them
yeah so that's a small subset of the 23
million health care workers in the
united states
actually one in five americans has a job
connected to health care in some way
that is not the first tier first in line
group in my opinion
one of the one in five americans that
has a job connected to health care
nursing homes and front line covet
health care workers not all health care
workers
not even myself so you have not yet
gotten your first
dose yeah i will not be getting the
covet 19 vaccine
until every high-risk american has been
offered at first
let's get our nursing homes and
high-risk and oldest americans immunized
first gosh
we've lost 10 percent of our nursing
home population
in the united states from kovid the case
fatality rate is
as high as 20 percent last week was the
deadliest week in nursing homes in
america
let's put our vulnerable people ahead of
ourselves we are seeing
mega sites now in different states big
stores being set up as a place or
even a stadium now i mean that must
encourage you
yeah it's good i mean they're trying
this helps address the confusion
about where do i go do i sign up do i
talk to my doctor like the primary care
doctors are sick of getting phone calls
for answers they don't have right and
for most people i tell them go to your
hospital
website or go to your cvs pharmacy
walgreens local pharmacy whatever it may
be and there'll be some information
there for the general public the
vaccine's generally not out there yet
how am i going to know and a lot of
people wonder this how am i going to
know when i'm
my time i'm like you i'm toward the back
of the line
even probably farther back from you how
will i know when hey i can get one
from those pharmacy websites or local
department of health websites otherwise
someone's going to call me though i have
to keep looking right
that's right no one's going to call you
you've got to be your own advocate
you've got to check those websites
keep looking it's honestly different by
state by county by medical center by
pharmacy
so keep asking and remember if you're
30 years old and have no health problems
step aside a little bit in the vaccine
line until the oldest people get it
first
and a message that's not been out there
that needs to be out there
is that if you've had covid you don't
need the vaccine right now
step aside natural immunity from
previous infection is pretty good
get in the back of the vaccine line and
let's put vulnerable people first
now some still don't want to get it some
want to wait there are anti-vaxxers out
there who don't want any vaccine
whatsoever
is that number getting less now is it
going down
versus the way it was say in the fall
first of all i respect people who don't
want to get
the vaccine right now i respect that
decision it's a personal decision
everyone's got to make it themselves
i think they should get it i will be
getting it
and i believe it's safe i just haven't
gotten it yet because i want to
use my you know take my time
i don't want to take it away from people
who need it before me first
but there's a couple myths out there and
i think get
understanding that it's not incorporated
in your dna is helping
people understand that it is safe
i think when people see others get it
they're more they feel more
willing to get it themselves after elvis
got the polio vaccine
a lot more people were willing to get it
what's going to happen
as the vaccine becomes more and more
available do you think that there will
be
more companies and schools that are
going to require people to have it
i think it will be very difficult for
them to do that i'm
morally opposed to any company requiring
the vaccine
because first of all it's under an
emergency use authorization second of
all i don't like the precedent of a
an employer telling you that you have to
have a chemical
injected into your body i just don't
like that i don't like the direction of
that
we actually have a precedent for that in
healthcare with flu shots
healthcare workers are required as a
condition of employment
to get the flu shot but i just generally
don't like that concept
around something where there may not be
good research or good data for example
why would you require someone to get the
covet vaccine
if they already have antibodies from
having had the infection
in the past that is they have natural
immunity that's an area where the
scientific community has had a huge
fumble
they completely messed up the natural
immunity thing they've never messaged
to people who had the infection in the
past hey here's what we know
on the data from natural immunity and so
where we you know a third of the country
may have natural immunity right now
if you think about it 23 million
infections
means 100 million to 200 million people
have had the infection because we're
only diagnosing
and confirming one in five to one in ten
cases over the course of the pandemic
so um i don't like the idea of requiring
the vaccine i don't think it will happen
i think a lot of us will continue to
speak up when we hear whispers of that
now there's a report in los angeles that
once the vaccine is available
for children which is not yet that they
want to make it a requirement like you
know
in some school districts you have to
have the vaccine for the measles and
mums for kids or you can't get into
school
public school first of all
let's be rational to to this school
district who's thinking about doing it
let me tell you
and and i encourage them to give me a
call our research shows that no child in
the united
states that we've found has died of
covid19
who has been healthy without a
comorbidity of the roughly 200 people
under age 20 who have died of covid19
in a study of half of the nation's
medical data we have found that all
had a comorbidity so let's recognize
that
maybe a child with a severe comorbidity
be it cerebral palsy or significant
diabetes and obesity
maybe they are the ones at risk and
maybe they should be strongly encouraged
to get it or at least be given the
information
the idea that somehow you have to
immunize all children to prevent
you know people from dying kids from
dying
i think it's not supported by the data
there are people who are saying look
we've had all these lockdowns and
restrictions especially since
thanksgiving
like in california but in california
it's as bad as it's ever been
it's not working do you agree with that
well it's not working anywhere is the
reality i know look i
i i i've been very critical of what
california has done in closing beaches
closing outdoor restaurant
uh restaurants some of that stuff to me
um
were very bad policy decisions and
you know i'd like to pile on to
california
but the reality is that florida is not
doing much better when you talk about
the overall mortality per capita rate
um a lot of the country has struggled
and so i think what you're
more likely likely to conclude from
looking at the experience of floor of
california is that
some of these extreme measures has not
reduced
the burden of infection more so than
states that have had less extreme
measures like florida and has more of an
outdoor society
now to me that doesn't mean florida is
right
it just means that california has not
increased the amount of protection
through overly excessive policies
nowhere in the country has done
exceptionally well
are we out of this in the summer or in
the fall
or at all this year i think like people
are
people are getting stir crazy and we
want to know we wanted to be home for
i want to be like i want to i want it to
be over too
um i think that
by april and may we're going to see herd
immunity levels
that the general scientific community is
not is not anticipating
in other words i'm predicting we're
going to see herd immunity quicker
than you're going to hear other experts
state and the reason is
they're under counting the number of
people with natural
immunity that can happen and i think it
will happen in march and april
and then the fall will probably feel
like a really bad flu season
but people will be on their guard and
you're going to see a lot of precautions
you're going to see a lot of people
use masks selectively maybe some places
may even still require it
it'll probably look like a bad flu
season in the fall
dr marty mccary professor at johns
hopkins fox news medical contributor
thanks so much for joining us
great to be with you
[Music]
new from the fox news podcasts network
my name is kennedy and welcome
to my podcast which will i humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome
it's kennedy saves the world subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
raiden review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
cal
thomas what's on your mind twitter and
facebook have permanently banned
president trump from their social
platforms
former national security adviser michael
flynn and attorney sydney powell
have also been permanently banned as
twitter announced a purge of quote
accounts dedicated to sharing content
related to the far-right q anon
conspiracy theory unquote
trump has now also been banned from
instagram snapchat
and twitch and parlor the alternative
social media platform favored by
conservatives
now finds itself virtually homeless on
the internet as
amazon apple and google have all booted
it from their platforms in a span of a
little more than 24 hours
the american civil liberties union has
expressed concern over the action by the
social media giants
in a statement kate rouen the aclu
senior legislative council said quote
we understand the desire to permanently
suspend him now
but it should concern everyone when
companies like facebook and twitter
wield the unchecked power to remove
people from platforms
that have become indispensable for the
speech of billions
especially when political realities make
those decisions easier
unquote the late writer nat hendoff in
addition to being an authority on the
history of jazz
was also a fierce defender of the right
to free speech
he once told me the answer to speech you
don't like
is not less speech but more speech
banning offensive speech
encourages radicals in their extremism
we no longer talk
to each other too many read and listen
only to what supports their point of
view
and demeans people who believe
differently this is unhealthy for a free
society
facebook and twitter made their decision
after the president
incited his followers to storm the u.s
capitol last wednesday
to stop lawmakers from formalizing joe
biden's election victory
perhaps they believe they have nothing
to fear from a democrat majority
congress
republicans in the senate had been
holding hearings into charges by
conservatives
that social media outlets censor
conservative opinion
with democrats in control of the senate
additional hearings are unlikely to be
forthcoming
in another display of the double
standard the two social media giants
still allow the iranian
leadership and people associated with
the chinese communist party
to maintain their accounts distrust by
many conservatives of virtually all
media has given rise to fringe platforms
that seek to tear us further apart and
undermine democracy
while claiming to protect it these
divisions have deepened since the
november election
as trump supporters believe the election
was rigged trump voters deserve to have
their concerns addressed
or the cynicism and division will only
get worse as will the potential for more
violence
the best way to lower the temperature
would be to create a forum that would
fairly and accurately examine
all claims of voter fraud and ballot
manipulation
as for attempts to ban speech some
people don't like i give you the lyrics
from the 1960s musical hair
let the sun shine in indeed let it in
because sunshine and free speech can
lead to the mind's true liberation
i'm cal thomas
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes